Навпроти мене - Віктор Медведчук, український політик,
глава адміністрації президента в 2002-2005 роках,
коли президентом був Леонід Кучма, і лідер громадського об'єднання,
громадського руху "Український вибір - право народу".
Вікторе Володимировичу, дуже дякую за те, що знайшли час на це інтерв'ю,
і ласкаво просимо в програму. Ви нещодавно повернулися з Москви, яка була мета вашого візиту?
Мета візиту до Москви, як це зазвичай відбувається протягом уже кількох років, -
це переговори, пов'язані в першу чергу з миром на Донбасі,
мирним урегулюванням, виконанням мінських угод.
І друге важливе питання, яке теж належить до схеми реалізації мінських угод, -
це звільнення утримуваних осіб.
І якщо раніше ми в Москві говорили переважно про тих осіб,
громадян України, які відбувають покарання або яких притягують
до кримінальної відповідальності на території Російської Федерації,
то віднедавна, враховуючи вплив Росії на представників керівництва невизнаних республік,
це ще й звільнення утримуваних осіб у Донецьку й Луганську.
А з ким ви зустрічалися в Москві?
Ну, в Москві я зустрічався з багатьма представниками керівництва Російської Федерації,
зокрема й із президентом Російської Федерації, паном Путіним.
Які результати цих переговорів?
Результати зазвичай бувають тоді, коли це бачать і знають усі, коли ми підходимо до фінішної прямої,
коли звільняють людей або є зрушення в питанні мирного врегулювання.
Казати про те, що цих результатів вже досягнуто, не можна.
Але водночас треба говорити й акцентувати увагу на тому, що переговорний процес іде і
цей переговорний процес, особисто я впевнений, приведе до позитивного результату як в одному,
так і в іншому такому питанні. Такі перемови мають продовжуватися.
Вікторе Володимировичу, вас в Україні вважають представником Володимира Путіна
або рукою Володимира Путіна. Чи дійсно ви представляєте його інтереси в українській політиці?
Ну, ви знаєте, я не думаю, що пану Путіну, президенту Російської Федерації,
потрібні представники в Україні, які б представляли його політику. Я вважаю, що більше необхідна
сьогодні Україні людина або люди, які могли б спілкуватися напряму і з представниками
керівництва Російської Федерації, зокрема й з представниками керівництва невизнаних республік
у Донецьку і у Луганську, ще раз підкреслюю, напряму.
Для того, аби досягати якогось результату, аби шукати й знаходити
спільний знаменник у тих питаннях, які є актуальними як з боку України,
так і з боку сьогодні цих невизнаних республік чи неконтрольованих територій.
Тому в цьому випадку те, що я роблю в Москві, я виконую прохання президента України,
пана Порошенка. Як в одному питанні, питанні обміну й звільнення тих осіб, які перебувають в Росії
та на неконтрольованій території в Донецьку й Луганську, так і у питаннях можливих шляхів поступу
в реалізації мінських угод, які були підписані в лютому 15-го року.
Чому президент Порошенко обрав саме вас посередником в переговорах між Україною і Росією?
Ну, тут все дуже просто. І пан Порошенко сам це пояснив, абсолютно, кілька тижнів або місяць тому,
коли його запитали щодо мене, він сказав, що пан Медведчук – найефективніший переговірник
з питання звільнення утримуваних осіб. Чому? Тому що у нього є особисті відносини з паном Путіним.
Я правильно розумію, ви наводите завжди той самий прагматичний аргумент на користь того, щоб
відновити відносини з Росією (ви казали про це і в інших інтерв'ю, які нещодавно давали), -
це, власне, економіка. І, власне, справді, Україна дуже залежить від Росії в економічному плані
і ви знаєте що…
Я б сказав, не залежить. В України є інтерес у розвитку подальших економічних зв'язків
із країнами СНД і, у першу чергу, з Росією. Ми можемо інший бік взяти, давайте візьмемо інший…
Я просто хотіла запитати концептуально, не кажучи про економіку, тобто ви бачите майбутнє України
як регіональної держави, де пальму першості утримує Росія, правильно я вас розумію?
Ні, неправильно. Я вважаю, що треба вибудовувати…
Яке ваше бачення?
Я вважаю, що треба вибудовувати в економіці прагматичні відносини.
А в політиці?
Якщо завтра… зачекайте хвилинку. Політика – це похідна від економіки.
Вибачте, але в Україні біда полягає в тому, що ми на перше місце ставимо політику
і політика формує економіку. А має бути все навпаки. Тому що саме в економіці, а не у політиці, -
інтереси людей. Інтереси тих людей, щодо яких за останні чотири роки відбулися страшні наслідки.
Коли газ для населення подорожчав на 960% із 1 січня 2014 року, електроенергія - на 535%,
середні зарплати зменшились удвічі, я ці цифри можу перераховувати довго і нудно,
вибачте за цей вираз, то ми тоді й кажемо, що питання не в політиці,
а питання в рівні життя людей.
Чи вважаєте ви, що Москва і політичне керівництво Росії, саме Володимир Путін,
використовує економіку для досягнення своїх політичних інтересів?
Ні, не використовує.
Не використовує?
Категорично ні. Поясню, чому. Ви знаєте про всі судові справи між "Газпромом" і "Нафтогазом"
в останні чотири роки?
Знаю.
Ну як же можна забезпечити стабільний транзит газу з Росії до Європи,
коли мова йде, перше, про газові поставки й претензії, про транзит, ціни й поставки.
Це що - стабільний шлях забезпечення газом Європи?
Ні.
Вікторе Володимировичу, зрозуміла вашу позицію, хочу все-таки змінити дещо тему.
А хто насправді винен у розв'язанні збройного конфлікту на Донбасі? Від самого початку.
Дивіться, я не вважаю Росію в цій ситуації агресором.
Чому?
Тому що сьогодні, якщо казати про Росію як агресора, тоді треба перекреслити і поставити хрест,
що я й сказав, оцінюючи цей закон, на мінських угодах. Адже у тих, хто підписував мінські угоди,
в їхньому представництві і в їхньому затвердженні, спочатку нормандською четвіркою голів держав,
чотирьох, ви знаєте яких, а потім і в рішенні Ради безпеки ООН, яка затвердила ці угоди,
було закладено глибокий сенс.
Цей сенс полягав ось у чому. Є Франція, є Німеччина, є Росія та Україна. Так ось,
Росії первісно відводилася роль країни, яка може здійснити вплив у тій чи іншій частині
на неконтрольовані території, на невизнані республіки в питаннях реалізації мінських угод.
Тож, виходить, Росія є стороною конфлікту, якщо Росія здійснює вплив на окуповані території?
Абсолютно неправильно. Абсолютно. Первісно, у даному разі, цей формат передбачав у тому числі й
тристороння контактна група, те, що Росія і ОБСЄ виступають посередниками. Але не стороною
конфлікту. І це безпосередньо записано у мінських угодах. Це затверджено рішенням Ради безпеки.
Вікторе Володимировичу, у мене запитання до вас як до інсайдера. Хто розв'язав збройний конфлікт
на Донбасі? Хто винуватець того, така величезна кількість військовополонених, якими ви займаєтесь? Хто?
Я ще раз кажу. Конфлікт, який мав місце і розв'язався десь наприкінці березня –
на початку квітня на Донбасі, це конфлікт між людьми, які перебували на Донбасі і які
не погодились із приходом нової влади і з політиками нової влади. Це був протест …
Тобто це - громадянська війна, правильно?
Ні, я би так не визначив. Це протистояння громадян однієї частини країни стосовно інших.
Сторони конфлікту - це, відповідно, різні групи у різних частинах України?
Саме так.
У мене до вас таке запитання, ось ви самі казали в інтерв'ю "Новій газеті",
що такого масштабного обміну полоненими,
кий відбувся 27 грудня 2017 року,
це було б неможливим, якби Володимир Путін не подзвонив головам невизнаних республік.
Цілком правильно.
Так Володимир Путін і Росія – не причетні до цього конфлікту?
Чому ж тоді вони його слухають?
Пояснюю. Я це пояснив у відповіді на два питання ваших попередніх.
Я не зрозуміла пояснення,
чому Володимира Путіна слухають.
Я вам пояснюю, Росія присутня в нормандському форматі й узяла на себе функції
зі здійснення впливу на керівництво невизнаних республік.
І в цьому випадку це – приклад і підтвердження того,  як Росія вплинула
посприяла у найбільш масштабному обміні полоненими,
починаючи від 14-го року.
Це ще одне підтвердження ролі Росії, яку не можна називати агресором,
якщо ми хочемо добитися миру на Донбасі.
Я правильно розумію, що голови невизнаних республік ДНР та ЛНР
не підкоряються Кремлю? З вашої точки зору.
Я не знаю жодного нормативного акту, на підставі якого
керівництво невизнаних республік підкоряється комусь в Росії.
Ви мені як юристу вкажіть такі нормативні акти,
Я готовий дискутувати.
Нормативних актів немає. Ви посилаєтесь дуже часто на мінські угоди
і, зокрема, стверджуєте, що на Донбасі немає російських регулярних військ.
Це не я стверджую. Це стверджує СММ ОБСЄ,
яка там перебуває в кількості 1000 осіб.
Зачекайте, давайте, ви любите юридичні документи… Я теж це знала.
Я зараз хочу послатися на юридичний документ, на який ви часто…
Давайте, із задоволенням.
… на який ви часто посилаєтесь.
Так ось, ці мінські угоди, я справді помітила, що в пункті 10
вказано, що необхідне виведення іноземних збройних формувань.
Про які іноземні збройні формування йдеться, якщо цей конфлікт,
якщо це фактично – громадянська війна?
Які формування мають бути виведені з точки зору мінських угод?
По-перше, це не громадянська війна.
Я вам вже сказав, що я цього терміну не визнаю.
Це перше. Друге, з приводу іноземних збройних формувань.
Добровольці з одного і з іншого боку,
і в одних, і в інших військові підрозділи завжди мали місце,
раніше і мають місце досі.
Мова йде про те, щоб будь-які іноземні збройні формування не були там,
коли будуть виконуватися повністю пункти і статті мінських угод.
Мова йшла саме про це.
Але там також йдеться не лише про іноземні збройні формування,
про добровольців і таке інше і тому подібне …
Там же не йдеться про те, що це – російські?
Я тому запитую, які?
Так, я вам кажу:
Диявол у деталях…
Ті, які… Там, наприклад. Ви знаєте, наприклад, про те, що воював там грузинський батальйон?
Я багато чого знаю.
А знаєте, що там добровольці з Чечні були, знаєте?
Так це хіба не іноземні збройні…
Іноземні. Про це йде мова?Добровольці з Чечні..
Ви знаєте, там добровольці були з Чечні.
Колись з України, в першій та другій чеченській війні,
брали участь українці в дуже великій кількості.
Це ж не були збройні формування України?
Ні, мова не йде про регулярну армію…
Більше того, не тому що там записано,
мова не йде про регулярну армію, тому що СММ ОБСЄ,
яка єдина покликана за мандатом, який вони отримали
від 57 країн світу,
регулювати й контролювати наявність і походження усього,
що можна віднести до бойових дій
або до збройного протистояння,
ніколи не вказували про наявність регулярних частин
Російської Федерації на території, непідконтрольній Україні.
Друге питання, знову ж таки, до мінських угод.
Відведення важких озброєнь. Другий пункт мінських угод.
Тут називаєтся низка, так би мовити, озброєнь,
які перебувають на озброєнні в російської регулярної армії.
Зокрема, "торнадо С".
Нічого не можу вам сказати.
Ця РСЗВ надійшла на озброєння російської армії у 2012 році.
Як вона опинилась на окупованих територіях?
Це посилання у вас на що?
На мінські угоди, другий пункт.
Ні-ні, а ось… вид озброєння, який ви зараз називаєте.
Торнадо… там вказані всі ці озброєння.
А це звідки? Вид озброєння, який перебуває на території непідконтрольній…
Це другий пункт мінських угод.
Ні, там не може бути вказане озброєння.
Там є "Торнадо С, "Ураган, "Смерч"
і тактичні ракетні системи "Точка". "Точка У".
Ні, в мінських угодах не перераховуються озброєння.
Там перераховуються важкі озброєння і калібри безпосередньо озброєнь.
А звідки воно там опинилося,
якщо дійсно навіть я довіряю, що у вас правильна інформація?
У мене правильна інформація.
Мені про це невідомо.
Це треба поставити запитання самій ОБСЄ.
Вони повинні тоді підтвердити те, що є таке озброєння і звідки воно там з'явилося.
Або висловити версію.
Я упевнений, що вони будуть ось так петляти…
А вже, вибачте, якщо вони не дають конкретну відповідь, то як я можу дати?
Хочете, можу поцікавитися.
У Володимира Путіна, мабуть, поцікавитеся?
Я подумаю, у кого поцікавитися. Ви не хвилюйтеся.
От ви кажете про те, що на Донбасі воюють різні,
тобто це війна між різними територіями, у яких - різні уявлення
про те, як має розвиватися Україна.
Зокрема, так.
Але ж на цю війну потрібні гроші?
Ось звідки у сепаратистів гроші на те, щоб продовжувати військові дії?
Ніколи не запитував про це. З однієї простої причини.
Ті питання, з приводу яких я веду переговори,
не передбачають такого глибокого й непотрібного для мене інтересу.
Тому що якщо я буду цікавитися так глибоко тими питаннями,
я думаю, що у мене нічого не вийде з переговорами з головних питань.
вважаю, що цим повинні цікавитися інші. Хто це має робити?
Якщо це цікавить сьогоднішню нашу українську владу, то президент Порошенко
має визначити і хай вони цим цікавляться. Може, вони це знають.
Ви цього не знаєте?
Ні, я цього не знаю. Навіть не хочу знати.
Ви казали нещодавно, що ви з 2014 року
перебуваєте в санкційних списках США.
Це не я казав, це США кажуть.
Ні, ваш представник, ваш прес-секретар,
який люб'язно нам організував це інтерв'ю, за що йому велике спасибі…
Від 17 березня 2014 року.
Ви перебуваєте в санкційних списках. Тепер точна є дата.
А як США пояснюють те, що вони включили вас до санкційного списку?
Ви знаєте, враховуючи глибину істинно взірцевої демократії Сполучених Штатів Америки
і, як вони стверджують, їхньої правової системи,
вони нічого ныкому не пояснюють.
І я вам скажу одну цинічну річ.
В них навіть немає механізму оскарження цих санкцій.
Не існує. В Європейському Союзі є спеціальний суд,
який розглядає питання скасування санкцій,
які накладаються ЄС.
Ви знаєте, що багато політиків пройшли цей шлях.
У багатьох це вийшло, комусь відмовили,
а от у США  як взірці демократії (я це все у лапки беру),
як взірці правової системи, взагалі жодної демократії,
жодної правової системи не існує в цій частині.
Тому вони це ніяк не пояснюють.
Якщо ви хочете знати, що офіційно вказано в тих документах,
в результаті яких я ці санкції отримав,
там написано про те, що пан Медведчук очолював
громадський рух "Український вибір", який відстоює федералізацію України.
Мабуть, ті, хто писав, забули про те, що вони живуть теж у федеративній системі координат.
Адже США є федерацією.
Далі. Пан Медведчук є особистим близьким другом президента Російської Федерації Путіна
і допомагав Януковичу здійснювати подібні зв'язки.
Ось приблизно те, що написали в цих санкціях.
Ну, абсурд, дурість.
Але цей абсурд і дурість не можна ані оскаржити, ані цьому протидіяти.
Тому я абсолютно спокійно до цього ставлюсь.
Ну, є санкції, ну… звичайно, це недобре.  Ну, нормально.
Це відносини і оцінка моєї діяльності США.
точно так ставився до США завжди.
І сьогодні - як один з найактивніших опонентів політики Сполучених Штатів Америки в Україні,
тому що вважаю, що США, починаючи з 14 року,
запровадили зовнішнє управління в Україні,
й  нині від цього постраждали і суверенітет, і незалежність нашої країни.
Так, ви казали, що вважаєте, що США ввели зовнішнє управління,
що посол США в Україні – це головна людина,
оловний гравець на політичному…
Не лише казав, і кажу.
Так, казали і я не сумніваюся, що ви не змінили свою точку зору...
І, до речі, останні події про це є прямим підтвердженням.
Це конфлікт щодо НАБУ
Ні, у мене просто таке питання.
МВФ, про який ви теж казали, він є кредитором України.
І природно, як будь-який кредитор, ви і бізнесмен у тому числі, не лише юрист,
він зацікавлений в тому, аби позичальник загалом
виконував якісь ковенанти, відповідав певним кредитним умовам...
Ну так, зараз, наприклад, створити антикорупційний суд,
суто профільна МВФ вимога. Суто профільна.
Ні, стривайте, стривайте.
Але ж, звісно, кредитор зацікавлений, аби позичальник,
це держава, боролася з корупцією.
То чому ви вважаєте цю вимогу виявом зовнішнього управління США?
А, наприклад, той факт, що Володимир Путін подзвонив Захарченку або Пасічнику
або Плотницькому, не є проявом зовнішнього управління з боку Росії?
Абсолютно різні речі.
Поясніть.
Почнімо з пана Путіна. Путін попросив на моє прохання і на прохання
його Святості патріарха Кирила, аби він звернувся до керівників невизнаних республік у питанні
того обміну, переговори з якого велися цілий рік.
Для того, аби звільнити людей як з одного, так і з іншого боку лінії зіткнення. Це перше.
Друге. МВФ не пропонує, і США не пропонують. Вони вимагають і вимагають
не лише в питанні антикорупційного суду.
Вони зажадали зняти генерального прокурора. Наче ми – колонія, азійська чи африканська.
І цього генерального прокурора, як заявив пан Байден, зняли за одну годину.
Сьогодні НАБУ, яке здійснює боротьбу з корупцією серед вищих посадових осіб України, щодня
(ось я дивився вчора програму) і сьогодні бігає до американського посольства і радиться,
як зняти того ж Холодницького...  Я не знаю, винен Холодницький чи ні, я не знаю,
наскільки винен у чомусь Ситник, мені це невідомо. Але коли бігають до посольства США і радяться,
що робити, у мене виникає питання, а навіщо тоді влада в Україні?
А те, що, наприклад, Володимир Путін підтримував тих чи інших кандидатів на посаду президента,
це ви не вважаєте проявом зовнішнього управління?
Та що ви кажете? Може, давайте конкретизуємо?
Янукович.
І де він підтримував, як?
Він підтримував Януковича, коли Янукович втік…
Так він вже не кандидатом був, він вже президентом був, коли він втік.
Коли він був кандидатом, його підтримувала Росія, він вважався проросійським.
Потім вважається, що він не уклав в останній момент асоціацію, тому що його про це попросив
особисто Путін, що у них була зустріч, потім він втік і, вже коли перестав бути президентом,
коли його скинули, втік до Росії... От ви коли кажете,  Володимир Путін комусь подзвонив абощо,
у вас не викликає це жодної негативної реакції. А коли щось роблять США,
у вас це викликає хвилю обурення.
Чому обурення? У мене було обурення?
Мені видається… я демонструю принципове…
Дивіться, але я з вами абсолютно не згоден. Ви бачите, якщо Путін комусь подзвонив…
ну, по-перше, не комусь, а людям, у відомстві яких перебувала доля людей, яких треба було звільнити.
Це не комусь. Це тим людям, яким треба було. Це перше.
Тепер з приводу Януковича. Ви чомусь кажете про фінальну стадію присутності Януковича
в якості президента на території України. А я вам хочу сказати: на жодних виборах Росія ніколи
не підтримувала жодного з кандидатів. Чого не можна сказати про американців, європейців,
які робили це напряму. І я можу з вами дуже багато дискутувати в цьому питанні і ще більше
наводити аргументів, як це було в 14-му році, як це все відбувалось, і як робив Євросоюз,
що робив конкретно (і Америка) для того, аби влада змінилась, і хто прийшов до влади.
Тому, коли ви кажете з приводу Росії, з приводу Європейського Союзу і Америки,
давайте користуватись конкретними аргументами. Таких аргументів у мене є величезна кількість.
Але Росія так явно, так грубо і так цинічно у виборчий процес в Україні ніколи не втручалась.
А скажіть, будь ласка, ви доволі близько спілкуєтесь не лише з президентом Росії Володимиром Путіним,
але й у вас є ділові, як мінімум, контакти з Петром Порошенком.
Я спілкуюсь із паном Порошенком.
Так, ви спілкуєтесь з паном Порошенком. Більше того, він уперше пройшов до Верховної Ради України
за списками партії, яку ви на той момент очолювали, як заступник…
Ні, я очолював.
Очолювали, так? Отже, це був 98-й рік. Ви вважаєте, що президент Порошенко - не самостійний
в ухваленні рішень, що він діє за вказівкою Держдепу США і, не знаю, Єврокомісії, Брюсселя?
Я можу твердо сказати й не раз це казав. Сьогодні пан президент Порошенко перебуває під впливом
і Євросоюзу, і США. Але вплив і дії без вказівки – це повністю різні речі.
Я казав і буду повторювати: у президента Порошенка, наскільки мені відомо з тих зустрічей,
розмов і дискусій, є політична воля мирного врегулювання.
Але в нього абсолютно відсутній політичний ресурс.
І цей політичний ресурс йому можуть організувати ті ж Сполучені Штати або Євросоюз.
Що вони намагались, якщо ви спостерігали за цією ситуацією, робити і у 16-му, і в 17-му році.
Але поки, на жаль, безуспішно.
Я хочу вам кілька особистих питань поставити.
Звичайно, один з відомих фактів про вас полягає в тому, що хрещеним батьком вашої доньки Дарини є
президент Володимир Путін, а хрещеною матір'ю - Світлана Медведєва.
Так, Світлана Володимирівна Медведєва.
Так, дружина Дмитра Медведєва, прем'єр-міністра. А якою була передісторія, чому ви вирішили, що
саме президент Путін має бути хрещеним батьком вашої доньки?
Ну, по-перше, у мене були відносини тоді дружні з паном Медведєвим,
ми були головами адміністрацій. Я - в Україні, він - у Росії. У мене були нормальні ділові відносини
з паном Путіним, і просто десь в розмові виникло… це питання з приводу того, що це був 2004 рік,
у мене народилась донька 20 травня. А ось десь там восени була розмова,
я звернувся з таким проханням і вони погодились з цим.
Тобто можна сказати, що Володимир Путін - ваш близький друг?
Ну, ви знаєте, коли мова йде про таку людину, то таке запитання можна ставити лише їй.
Чи вважає він когось близьким другом. А мені некоректно про це казати.
Вважає, як вам видається? Він довіряє вам як…
людині, котра нині відповідає за переговорний процес?
Я вважаю, що у пана Путіна є до мене довіра.
Ви ніколи не шкодували про те, що тоді ухвалили це рішення, коли ще не було цілком очевидно,
що відносини наших країн настільки сильно погіршаться, зокрема, через війну на Донбасі?
Ні, не шкодував. Ви ж знаєте, кажуть, що це ухвалюється рішення там, нагорі.
Таке рішення, мабуть, було ухвалено і тому так сталося.
Як ставляться в Україні до того, що ви так близько пов'язані з Володимиром Путіним?
Ну ви знаєте, ви ж знаєте, як ставляться в Україні до цього?
Велика кількість людей, які це негативно сприймають. Але є і ті, які це схвалюють.
І схвалюють у першу чергу тому, що, особливо сьогодні, у мене є певні відносини з паном Путіним, і
я намагаюсь, цього не приховую, використовувати їх в інтересах України.
Нещодавно в Росії відбулися президентські вибори, ви вже з Володимиром Путіним зустрічались
після того, як вони пройшли. Як ви взагалі ставитесь до того, що Володимир Путін пішов
на четвертий термін?  Що фактично в Росії немає змінюваності влади.
Ви знаєте, я знаю про те, що він пішов на другий термін. А ви - на четвертий?
Так, на четвертий термін.
Він буде учетверте президентом. А пішов він на другий термін.
Загалом це – четвертий термін. Обійшовши, справді, те, що, відповідно до Конституції,
неможливо балотуватися на два терміни поспіль. Як ви до цього ставитесь?
Я до цього ставлюсь винятково позитивно.
Ви - не лише впливова людина в Україні, очевидно, і у Росії теж. Але ви – доволі заможна людина.
От ви все ж постійно займались політичною діяльністю. В який момент вам вдалося заробити
таку кількість грошей, якою б вона не була?
Дуже легке питання для мене. Починаючи з 92-го року, я займаюсь активно бізнесом.
І, до речі, з 92-го року декларую всі свої прибутки в Україні. Я прийшов у політику в 97-му році і,
на відміну від інших українських політиків, які так багато говорять про свої заробітки, про свої статки,
про свої політичні погляди, я продав увесь свій бізнес. Я не переписав ані на дружину, ані на братів.
В 97-му році?
Так, я продав. І я перебував у політиці з 97 року, коли я був депутатом Верховної Ради,
потім я був заступником ВР, першим заступником, потім головою адміністрації, до 2005 року.
В 2005 році я пішов і знову почав займатися активно бізнесом і займаюсь ним останні 13 років.
Тому те, що я – заможна людина, це факт. І те, що статки я набув у результаті законного бізнесу,
який вів з 92 до 97 та з 2005 веду до 2018-го, щоправда, в особливих умовах і з багатьма
обмовками, з урахуванням американських санкцій, це факт.
Я бачила в Ютубі відео, де до вас Володимир Путін приїздив у гості на дачу в Криму.
Так.
Воно було розміщене у 2012 році, не знаю, коли воно було зроблене...
В 12-му? Так, у 12-му, правильно, в 12-му й було.
Яка доля вашої вілли в Криму?
Я там відпочиваю щороку. І збираюсь цього року.
Так, а їздите через українську територію чи через російську?
Їжджу на законних підставах.
А це які підстави?
Ну, через українську територію, звичайно.
Тобто вона у вас залишилась?
Так, вона залишилась у власності тих структур, які належать моїй родині, в даному разі дружині,
більше того, все абсолютно нормально.
А там потрібно якісь документи переоформлювати?
Так, перереєстрацію пройшли, у нас, у громадян України, дуже багато власності на території…
І те, хто мали для цього правові підстави, вони автоматично всі перереєстрували..
Хоча багато суперечок, але суперечки виникали тільки переважно через те,
що не було законних підстав для оформлення ще… в тому житті…
Дякую вам велике.
Будь ласка.